"These are the times that try men's souls.
The summer soldier and the sunshine patriot
will, in this crisis, shrink from the service
of his country. But he that stands it now
deserves the love and thanks of man and woman."
Thomas Paine, "The American Crisis." December
19th, 1776.
America has had many crises since the winter
of 1776, though none so bleak as that first
one. We're in a crisis now, caused by a falling
away from the principles of 1776.
The immediate way to understand the American
crisis is the fact that the government is
at the point of becoming an unlimited government.
I mean, goodness, it's about to bankrupt the
richest country in the history of man.
It is a crisis unlike anyone that is previously
met, because it is self-inflicted and it is
wholly avoidable.
America has been in a slow-motion emergency
since Progressivism began to erode our Constitutional
foundations.
We are the last best hope of the world and
we're into, in my mind, a very, very unfortunate
period of turning our back on first principles.
We have to fight for our liberty and if we
don't have a rebirth in learning and liberty,
we're going to lose it.
Any political renewal in the United States
will start from, be based on, the two great
documents, the Declaration and the Constitution,
which means it begins with the study of those.
In the mind of the Founding Fathers, what
is the responsibility of government?
Because our college has never forgotten those
principles, never abandoned that task, we're
going to help provide that spark.
The Founding Fathers, through the Declaration
of Independence, held that all men are created
equal. They're endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights, that among those
are life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness.
Let's try to figure out what those things
meant. Yes?
In the USA we were founded on universal principles,
and the answer key, if you will, for those
principles, is the Declaration of Independence.
The explicit purpose of government is to preserve
those rights from any intrusions of government
on that individual.
Yes, ma'am?
That's what the role of government does. It
doesn't give us a right. We have our natural,
inherent rights, from God, and the government
is there to protect those for us.
I think the most important word in the Declaration
is "secure." Governments are instituted among
men to secure their rights, not give us rights.
The rights pre-exist government.
Inspired by the ideals of America's founding,
a small group of ministers started a college
out on what was then the frontier.
Hillsdale was founded in 1844 by a bunch of
New England preachers moving out on the edge
of civilization. They started it with next
to nothing. One of our founders went riding
his horse for two years around Michigan and
Indiana and Illinois and Ohio and Wisconsin.
We still have the list of the people who gave
three and five dollars at a time. Came back
with twenty-five thousand dollars, a princely
sum.
From the beginning they were guided by the
principles of the Declaration that all would
be welcome in the pursuit of the life of the
mind, regardless of gender and regardless
of race.
We think it may be the first institution in
history, anywhere, any time, any kind of institution,
with a charter that says, "We'll take our
student body without regard to race, sex or
national origin."
That's what civil rights leaders of the 60s
aimed for. If you said to Dr. King, "Fifty
years hence, what would you like the society
to be like?" I suspect he could look at Hillsdale
and say, "I'll take that."
Being lovers of freedom, the founders of Hillsdale
were deeply involved in the slavery crisis
and had a lot to do with the founding of the
party that elected Abraham Lincoln president.
The platform on which Abraham Lincoln was
elected President of the United States was
written, in the main, by two Hillsdale College
professors.
Lincoln said in the Gettysburg Address, "Four
score and seven years ago, our fathers brought
forth on this continent a new nation, conceived
in liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal." Where would
he have taken his instruction from ideas of
liberty? Yes, sir, Mr. Brooks?
He would have gotten the idea of liberty and
the United States being conceived in liberty
from the Declaration of Independence.
At the time, there were people arguing that
your rights came from things like your race
or your status in society, but Lincoln's argument
was that it came from your status as a human
being.
Yes, sir?
During the revolution, we claimed that all
men were created equal. In the Civil War,
we fought to prove that.
Walking the campus with Dr. Arnn, he stops
in front of the monument, and he says, "When
the Civil War broke out, every male student
left Hillsdale to enlist."
The Battle of Gettysburg would have gone differently
if there hadn't been about thirty or forty
boys from Hillsdale College in the worst place
in the battlefield. By the way, we didn't
make those boys go. We taught them to love
freedom, and they rallied to its defense.
The next major challenge to these principles,
the principles of the founding, emerged in
the late nineteenth century: Progressivism.
Woodrow Wilson, elected president in 1912,
became the first President to criticize the
American founding, which he did root and branch.
It was not a peripheral criticism. He said
the Founders may have been right in their
simple era, but we complex, modern people
with our complex, modern nation, know that
limited government's a mistake. Therefore,
the separation of powers is a mistake. Therefore,
the idea that government exists solely to
protect pre-existing rights is not nearly
ambitious enough.
He thought that his political science was
far in advance of the Founders and that we
needed a kind of re-founding of the country's
politics in order to stay abreast of the times.
I think Woodrow Wilson's thoughts make sense
at first glance, because he was saying, "How
can two documents from the seventeen hundreds
govern us in an age where now we have airplanes,
we have cars ..." I think it makes sense in
that regard. But when you think about the
fact that human nature has not changed ...
What Wilson is saying is essentially the exact
opposite, that things need to adapt and change
over time. In a sense, that they are not eternal.
Progressives believe that there are superior
intellects and that superior intellects ought
to help and sometimes coerce their fellow
human beings into a better state of perfection.
They're all about changing you and me, and
they are not about unchanging truths and natural
rights. They're about the perfectibility of
the human species. Very dangerous to believe
in that, and they do.
The Wilsonian tradition went from there to
today, where it's enthroned, as it were, in
the halls of Congress and in power. The Progressives
went from Woodrow Wilson to the presidency
of his former Assistant Secretary of the Navy,
Franklin Roosevelt, to Franklin Roosevelt's
young protégé from Texas, young Congressman
Lyndon Johnson, next to be president, to the
fourth transformative Progressive president,
Barack Obama.
As government continued to expand, inevitably
it intruded into higher education. Successive
administrations issued ever more onerous regulations,
forcing colleges to comply if they took Federal
money, which Hillsdale never had. Then the
government tightened the noose.
In the Carter administration, we heard from
the Department of Health, Education and Welfare.
They said, "We realize you don't take any
direct aid to the college from the Federal
government, but your students are getting
aid like the G.I. Bill. Because of that, we
get to regulate you comprehensively. Whatever
we want. Hundreds of pages of stuff. You have
to comply." We sued them, and the suit went
all the way to the Supreme Court and we lost.
To be free from government intrusion, we have
refused all Federal funding, direct or indirect.
The heavy hand of Liberalism would have been
brought to bear on education at Hillsdale,
both in terms of the content of the student
body, but eventually in terms of who was hired
for the faculty, what is being taught in the
classroom ... There really is a ... You would
be making a bargain with the devil if you
had conceded an inch to them on this question,
and to Hillsdale's credit, it did not concede
an inch.
A college is an expensive thing to run, and
most of our competitors are getting thirty
percent of what they call student revenues
from the government, and so we make that up.
We make that up by hundreds of thousands of
people have been generous with our college.
My mother died, left me a fortune. What better
way than to help people go to Hillsdale?
Wow, that's incredible.
Unlike the distant Federal government, Hillsdale's
donors know the students they support.
I'm working my way through college and I'm
just really, really grateful My parents, every
day, are so grateful as well.
I appreciate the letters I get from you all.
Good, good.
I really enjoy them. Highlight of my week.
Oh, good! I'm so glad.
Each one of these bubbles is full of the gas
methane.
Yeah!
With its hard-won independence, Hillsdale
is free to pursue truth and defend liberty.
Where are we going to go from here? What do
we want the college to be like in ten years?
The center of gravity will have shifted. What
is now an exciting on-campus phenomenon will
be recognized nationwide.
Because of its unique mission, Hillsdale has
drawn major international leaders to its campus
and events. The best of these speeches are
put into a publication called Imprimis, which
reaches millions of people nationwide.
I heard of it through a friend of mine who
I think was the first conservative I ever
met, and so he gave me a copy of Imprimis.
I need to make a switch on the October Imprimis.
My journey to a new political understanding
took a great deal of time and a certain amount
of salubrious pain. I was impressed, first
of all, by the exactitude of the writing in
Imprimis. It was academic in the best sense,
sort of tempted back to take one back to first
principles and to state them cogently.
Hi!
Good morning, Miss Louis. Could you tell me
a bit about your graduate school of statesmanship?
Here's a brochure-
This is the first graduate school at Hillsdale.
Its M.A.s and Ph.D.s in politics will spread
Hillsdale's learning to universities and other
institutions across the nation.
You'll be focusing mostly on the first principles
of American Constitutionalism and the fate
of those principles over time.
It gives a degree in the great books that
are necessary to understand the American Revolution
and politics and man in general.
They keep saying all we need is more regulation.
It seems like government's always the solution-
The Kirby Center in Washington, D.C., brings
Hillsdale students to the Capitol for classes
and internships. It also offers educational
programs for Washington policy-makers.
It's in the belly of the beast, speaking truth
to power. It's a kind of reverse-missionary
work in which, from the provinces you send
missionaries to the center, rather than the
other way around, and that's because they're
most needed in the center.
Hello and welcome to Constitution 201, Hillsdale's
online course on the Constitution and the
Progressive. My name's-
Hillsdale's free online classes for citizens
nationwide who want to learn.
What evidence do you have that it's possible
to recover the older understanding of the
Constitution?
Historical parallel would be Lincoln, who
did just this. He showed that it was possible-
Your first Constitution course, with two hundred
thousand people signed up to listen to the
great scholars of Hillsdale really, I think,
surprised me and surprised everyone else that
there was that kind of hunger for that kind
of serious but very winsome learning.
Please join us next week.
In every major crisis since the middle of
the nineteenth century, including the Civil
War, our college has played an important part,
and always the same part. We are faithful
to the things we were founded to do, and they
are just like the things that the country
was founded to do.
It sounds odd to say that this little college
in this little corner of southeastern Michigan
can lead a renewal, but it can.
One thing that has made me the most excited
about learning, I think, is looking at history
and seeing the ideas that have shaped our
own country, and that is what our purpose
is here, to become men and women of character
who make a difference in this country.
That's the lesson of Hillsdale. Let's create
a more just society. What guides do we have?
Oh, I get it. Let's go back to the Constitution.
Let's share this basic texts.
The threads that run through these books will
run through my own life and beyond; when I'm
not here anymore there's something of value
that continues on. I think that's what's so
beautiful about it.
Hillsdale is producing a generation of missionaries
for liberty, and that's a very good thing
for a world that's been long-starved for that.
We do it to produce a small leavening minority
that will radiate through the whole republic.
We can take that Greco-Roman and Judeo-Christian
heritage and see how America was founded upon
those ideals, and then we are stewards of
that education today. As we leave Hillsdale,
we take with us these ideas and we rise to
self-government through education.
The college has ever been faithful to its
founding principles, which are sound learning,
knowing the beautiful and the good and the
true things, in support of civil and religious
freedom and intelligent piety. That's what
the college is for. It's still for that.